le ville de new york s'apprête à baisser
victime pourtant après la tragédie la
question de l'indemnisation des familles
fait encore débat près de 700 dossiers
seulement ont été déposées comment
évaluer le prix d'une vie sur quels
critères fixés les bars eve en même
temps certaines familles ne veulent se
contenter de ça indemnisation et se
réserve le droit de poursuivre soit les
compagnies aériennes soient les pays qui
soutiennent encore al qaïda reportage
maryse burgot jean-françois c'était son
premier emploi mathieu selectour avait
24 ans il était si fier lorsqu'il avait
annoncé à son père qu'il travaillait
dans les tours du world trade center
c'est d'ailleurs son père qui l'a appelé
par téléphone
juste avant de mourir il a dit papa il
faut que je dise quelque chose c'est
très mauvais je veux que vous sachiez
combien je vous aime et je n'ai jamais
revu avant le 11 septembre les celi tôt
menait une existence paisible et
confortable dans la banlieue de new york
le fils aîné débutait une carrière
prometteuse dans la finance
un an après sa disparition ses parents
ont décidé comme mille autres familles
de porter plainte contre ceux qui
soutiennent financièrement les
terroristes
nous devons retirer l'argent des mains
des terroristes des organisations
charitables factice des princes d'arabie
saoudite vont alimenter financièrement
les réseaux terroriser nous avons des
traces et les preuves écrites de tout ça
et nous continuerons tant qu'ils auront
les ressources à s'entraîner
pour trouver des ormes et développer
leur arsenal d'armes chimiques jaune
quartier a lui aussi perdu un être cher
son frère james mais il a décidé de ne
pas se lancer dans des poursuites
judiciaires
il va donc accepté l'indemnisation
proposée par l'état en échange ils
renoncent en toute plainte contre une
compagnie américaine
mais aujourd'hui il s'insurge contre la
manière dont l'état évalue le coût d'une
vie
comment est ce qu ils peuvent se
regarder en face c'est se dire ok un
électricien de 26 ans vaut moins qu'un
pdg de 46 ans qui gagne 2 millions de
dollars par an mais comment ce qu'ils
peuvent faire c'est un million et demi
d'euros par victime fait ce que l'état
propose en moyenne les familles qui pour
fuir les compagnies aériennes ou les
propriétaires des tours pourrait
recevoir beaucoup plus